量子コンピューターはすべての問題に
適しているわけではありませんが、いくつかの問題のクラスと
潜在的なユースケースでは、
量子コンピューティングが影響を与えると期待されています。
それには、シミュレーション、たとえば
自然界で起こるプロセスやシステムのモデリング、
探索と最適化、
多くの候補の中から最良または
最適な解を見つけること、
そして数学や複雑な構造を持つデータの処理、
機械学習への応用なども含まれます。
量子アルゴリズムはこれらの問題に新しいアプローチをとり、
量子力学のユニークな特性、たとえば
重ね合わせ、干渉、もつれといった
特性を活用します。
従来のコンピューターは、計算空間の特定の領域を
探索する際に行き詰まってしまい、
特定の領域の探索で行き詰まるため、
これらのパターンを見つけられません。
量子コンピューターは、
追加の能力や性能向上を備えており、
量子的な性質によって一部の問題でその恩恵を受けられます。
量子コンピューターの可能性を完全に理解するには、
計算複雑性理論を深く掘り下げる必要があります。
これはコンピューターサイエンスの一分野で、
異なる種類の問題を解くのに必要な
計算コストの測定と比較を中心に扱います。
これは有益なフレームワークを提供し、
さまざまな高速化や
コンピューティングで遭遇する
問題クラスを説明するのに役立ちます。